.
HO ON,IDG VOTED IN THE
AFFIRMATIVE, THE MOTION IS NOT
AGREED TO.
>>AD PRESIDENT? MAJORITER.
E FLOOR.SINGLEBLICAN  ABOUT WHAT
JUSTOTED AGAINST STARTING DEBATN
MINORITCHED
ES HERE IN T OCKAD A
UNITEDTETAL THT TO VOTE.
COULD WE HAVORDER,
PRESIDENT?
>> THE SENATE WILL ORDER.
>> I HAVE LAID THETS FOR
LS
ACROSS THE ARE ENGAGED T SWEEPIT
TALIZING ON AND BY
DONALD TRUMP'S BIG L.
THATGOT HA,
POORERURN AN
IC
EARLIER Y, REPUBLICAN
SHOULD REPORTERS THAT,
QUOTE,
HAPPINE , THERE
NO RATIONAL FEDERAL
IN
LEADER FLATLY
STATES DO TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY, VOTER
LAWS, PHONDITSAN  LLECTIOBOARDS
COLLEAGUES,Y COLLEAGUES, IF
SENATORS 60 ARO HELD THE
DENT SHOULD NOT TERVENE TO PROT
RIGHTS BODY WOULD HAVE
NEVER PASSED VG RIGHTS
ACT.
RER USES THE
LANGUAGE AND THE LOGIC OE
SOUTHERN SENATORS INs
WHO FENDED STATE'S AND
IT IS AN
FOR ANSENATOR, A SENATOR,
T ALONE E MINORITYR TOHOLD.
AT THE REASON FOR WHRES VOTED
IN LOCK STEP TRE
HA HAPPENING IN SOME
STATESO RAL .
THAT IS BOTH RIDICULOUS
AWFUL.
D TO DO HEREN THE
OF VIN DEBATHOW OM.
THESE VI OFTENTIMES
G NSY EVER
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR STOOD
TOGETHER IN THE FIGHT TO PROTEI
SENATEIL UNITED
DEFENOUDEMOCRACY.
EAR S LL BEEN UNSHAKABLEORT OF H
ESEIFORTS.
BUREGRETTABLY,, FO BANIMOUS OPP
ONCE AGAIN, SENATE REPUBLICANS
THR DGER OST ALONGSIDE TRUMP, TI
VOTER SUPPRESSION TO THEIR
IS'M A TO SAY,
ISE  VSSION HA POF
FICIAL PLATFORM OFHEREPUBL PARTA
PREVD NG A RIGHTS TODAY, I WAO
ABOUT ONTHING.
THE FIGHT  PROTECT VOTIN
RIGHTS IBY NIG VOTIN,
NOT THNISH LINE.
OR VOTING RIGHTS,
THIS VOTE WAS THE  GUN, FI
AS MANY HAVE NOTED MY TOOCK THIS
MORN W WAS
ABOUT TO CT BRIDGE I
WAITED FOR HIM ON THE OTHE.
HE DIDN'T KNOWONS
S ULMA
NEVER GUARANTEED.
ANYWAY.STARTEDOWE
TODAY DEMOCRATTEOU
MARCH TO DEFEND TH ALL AMERICAN.
IT COULD BE A LOCHT IT
WE ARE IN MAKE.
TODAY WE MADE PROGRESS.
ME
DEMOCRS UNIFIED BEHIND MOVINFOR
BILL.
AND MAKE NO E ABOUT ITE LAST TI
TIS UP A
S MAY WANTO TOPIC, HOPTHIRS TO L
WILL GO
DEMOCRATS WILL NOTLL
NEVER LET THI
VOTEIO SWEPT UND
WE HAVRAL SERIOUS OPTIONS
CO VOTERESSION.ORE EVERY O
LAST ONE OF OUR S.E TOO
THISESSIONT ANE ARINABOUT IO
TIRELESSLY T II D THR. BDW?
>> THERE YOU HAVE IT.
50/50.
N FAVOR OF ENG NG UP THOT
OPPOSING.
THE REPUBLICANS WERE INVOLVED
A FILIBU WHE TNEED0
IN ORDE THE
SCR , BUT NOW Y , WE HEARD
CHANGE THE FILTERL   FIGHT FOR U
IS OIS.
U HEARD SCHUMER SAY
TH HE THE OFFICIAL
PLATFORM OF THE REPUBLRTD DEMOCE
, OBVIY,
IE THAT IS GOINGNY KIND  VOTERF,
EG
COUNTRY.
WE HAVE HEARD MITCH McCONNELFER
D THAT IS
WILL DESIBE .
SA THAT IN
TERMS OF WHAIAWAS
SAYING EARLIER, THISL
BILL INCLUDEE PUBLIC E
DEMOCRATS KNOW THAT REPUBLICANS
WERE NEVER GOING TO VOTE FOR.
WAS QUITE BROAD. CAME UP WITH S
REIC NUBT VOTE
AGAINST THAT GET TE QUESTION
FWHAT AREDEMOCRATS GOINTO DO A
IT?WILE RYRSTEN SEMUT
>> TPIG
RIGHTS LEGISLATION THAT ISN'T A
PART OF THIS BILL, WHI IS THE .
THEAVEN'THA
I THINK THEY'RE HOLD
SOTHATHER SUPPOR.TY
RULES FROM CERTAIN STATE THAPRET
TERMS  TTHEIR ON THE SUPREME CON
, JOHN PASSED, WAS PUTTING TOGE
THIS LEGISLAFI T, WE HBLICAN SE
MUOW POTENTIALLY
TO SOME THE JOHN
LEE CONVERSATION MONGHER WAYS TR
DEMOCRATIC T
RESTORE SOME OF THE PROTECTIONS
PU, THE , >>IDR L PRAC
THE REPUANS
AWS,
MAKING IT MORE RESTRICTIVE FOR N
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING
THESS NEW
>> YEAHE BATTLES WILL
IFT
TO THEOU
O SOUR THE NOTE OF
REALITY HERE ABOUT THE PROSPECTS
R  LEGISLATION, AND I
AGE THAT'S
SAID.
THEY MOVED AN 80GEAT
INCLUDED PUBLINANCING AND A
NEVER GOING TO PASHERE
I DON'T INR
VEIORE
EITHER.
SENATOCONNELL HAS ALREY
E THAT HDOESN'SUPPORT PASSG THS
EITHER.ONGRESS IS
I DON'T THINK WE NOW HAVE TW
DECRATORS WHO
DECL TOTAN TIBUSTER. S
EARLY AS IN "THE
SO RLL YAS NOT
THIS CONGRESS   IN
RIGHTS, THOUGHE SOME
MORE.
I K  THE SHOT OF A
FOR
THERE ARE A LOT OFVOTERS WHO FE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THIS WILL BE ACRY.
>> HOLD ON, DAVID.
I'M GOINTO INTERRUPT AGAIN. 'ME
OBVIOUSLY THIS IE OF THE STL ISD
TAKET THE RIIN OUR
COUNTRY.
CERTAINLY, FOR THEMERICAN